لم يجد موسى خالد ملاذا لحل مشكله الوقود
في منزله بمنطقه جرش الشماليه الاردن الا
بتقطيع اشجار حديقه
لطالم اعتمد موسى على الكيروسين المعروف
بالكاز للتدفئه لكنهما لبس ان تحول الى
الحطب بعد ارتفاع سعر صفيحه العشرين لترا
منه الى 22$
علشان اغطي فاتوره الكهرباء وفاتوره
المياه يعني اللي جاءت همم يعني استخدم
صوت الحطب لانه لو ما استخدم صوت الحطب
بدي 150 دينار اضافيه فبصير عندي هون عبر
الاقبال على شراء الحطب تضاعف مرات وانتشر
العديد من محل بيعه في طول البلاد وعرضها
مشهد يعكس ضعف قدره المواطنين على التكيف
مع اسعار المحروقات التي ارتفعت 16 مره
خلال عامين اعلنت الحكومه فيها مرارا انها
لن تقوم بخفض الضرائب على اسعار المحروقات
لكن توجها ملكيا الزمن في مستهل العام
الجديد بتجميد الضريبه على ماده الكيروسين
تحديدا خلال فصل الشتاء الحالي ليصبح سعر
الصفيحه الواحده 17 دولارا منخفاض قدره
خمسه دولارات التوجه الملكيه الاخير
بتجميد ضريبه على ماده اساسيه رئيسيه مثل
الكاز اثبت ان هنالك كان الاصرار الحكومي
ماضيا على انه لا يوجد بدائل عن فرض
الضريبه لالتزامها مع صندوق النقد الدولي
الذي يتشدد في موضوع او البرنامج
الاقتصادي مع الاردن في فرض الضرائب وجهه
اخواننا اليوم همم
بتجميد الضريبه على الكاس خلال وتبلغ كلفه
تجميد ضريبه ماده الكيروسين على خزينه
الدوله نحو 31 مليون دولار وفقا اقاده
اصحاب المحروقات بالاستهاد الى ان الطلب
عليها يقارب 140 مليون لتر سنويا ويؤكد
مختصون ان الاردن هو الاعلى في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والوطن العربي في اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه نظرا لتعدد وارتفاع
ضرائب عليها
هو بسبب الرفع المتكرر لاسعار المحروقات
شهد الاردن على مدار الشهر الماضي موجه
تحت جاجات خاصه من طرف سائقي الشاحنات
وباصات النقل العمومي رائد عواد الجزيره
جرش شماليه الاردن